I think it's something that no one in Japan knew about. The word rider is used
in Japan and when there aren't any cars, so it's a gas station, a
restaurant parking lot, and so on.  But I wonder if there are people,
so I posted it because we started in the lifestyle, but it was noticed
[Music]
My name is Shimodaira 11 This
is called Paradise Road in my shop
Work  My job is to import an old car and fix or remodel it so that it can run on Japanese roads.
I was attracted to myself. It's become a culture of human interaction,
such as going out to play and being invited to a party or being taken to a night run,
isn't it
?  I really like the culture of the lifestyle
, and unlike the car that is made from the amount of money and the people, it's a community that arises from it.
We also
created a club in 1985, following that.
[Music]
Our  The car club is called Faros, but
there is a movie that everyone who has a car hobby knows, and there is a bad kid's marker club that appears in the movie that says that it eats American,
but I took it from there.
There is a big event in Yokohama once a year, where you can see what Americans are originally shipping and inventing, and interacting with Japanese car making and our thoughts.  Well, it's not just low riders,
but American-style cars and bikes made by Japanese people come to see them on an airplane
. The
most surprising thing about this is probably living in California.  I'm glad that the total number of people
is so happy. It
's amazing that the culture that we started in the complicated lifestyle
spread all over the world
.  I'm sorry
[Music]